spoiler time now the one of the many
scenes that I really wanted to talk to
you about was the bar scene I mean
there's so many things I was struck by
in that scene the return of Jack and
also how it was all almost all shot in
profile shots so I'm just curious what
was it like approaching that and working
up said Henry Thomas it was lovely to
work with Henry I really really I really
liked him and and I've we had this very
emotional scene to play it struck me as
while we would do it I didn't anticipate
feeling so emotional playing that scene
because I read it much more angrily I
felt like it was you know he's he's
faced with his father again and he's
able to he wants some answers he wants
his father's he wants his father's love
you know and and his father and he's
looking for it and he's crushed to be
being further hurt by him again it was
almost it surprised me how upsetting it
was to play fun enough and it was just
wonderful to play with him was a very
long scene and we walked on set and it's
it's always there's always a heightened
energy when you've got a very long
dialogue scene like that because you sit
down and you know it's like four or five
minutes of we played it from start to
finish you know we didn't we didn't
break it up and it's lovely because a
bit like theater you just you you know
you find you just you you you not
anticipating anything you're just in the
moment with it and it was lovely to play
with him who's just lovely to hang out
with between takes and talked to and we
again had things in common and it was it
was lovely just loved it to work with
him I knew that that would be the most
controversial scene of the film I liked
guaranteed and I there were parts of it
I wanted to use exactly the same framing
you know that Kubrick used I wanted to
be that familiar down to you and when he
sits at the bar and finally makes eye
contact with the bartender he looks
right down the barrel the same way that
Jack did before we reveal the bartender
but after the scene had started I didn't
very intentionally did not want to live
in Kubrick's angles and one of the
things that was really a revelation for
me
was how living in a profile in a true
profile even being out of there I lines
so much made that scene feel so intimate
and uncanny to me it's one of the few
times that I was trying very hard not to
homage Cooper's coverage and I love the
bizarre feeling that it gave me and only
kind of coming frontal to you in in in
pockets and only coming around on Lloyd
you know one time at the very end it
just felt like the right balance but it
was one of the hardest scenes to crack
in editorial it was it was one of the
ones I agonized over kind of frame by
frame there there may be been 200
versions of that scene I haven't seen
how they've Evans I saw the film before
it was locked so I haven't seen how it's
ended up it wasn't all in profile when I
saw it so because they cut to the reveal
of him for like full-on yeah perfectly
timed right the shots were matched he
and us the scene with Jack in the
original film we lived they did the same
lenses the same angles the bottles
behind him are in are the same bottles
in the same order it's not just random
everything is absolutely perfect